la proposition du candidat dont il est
question c'est la blouse moi je suis
contre la blouse la question est seul
uniforme je suis pour l'uniforme je joue
pas sur les mots parce que les mots sont
importants pour moi l'uniforme ça peut
effectivement avoir du sens parce que
l'uniforme cc portait beau la blouse je
trouve que c'est un peu la tenue commune
au rabais de comment je préfère
effectivement dire oui à l'uniforme et
je veux dire pourquoi je dis ouais leaf
en or pour répondre à yann il a raison
donc c'est par cette question là qui
fait une politique d'éducation de calais
vie danse il ya tellement de sujets à
traiter au sein de l'éducation nationale
quatre cent cinquante pour cent des
gamins qui arrivent en sixième qui
savent pas lire ils savent pas écrire
est que ça va pas compter et qui
maîtrise pas les fondamentaux donc je
pense effectivement qu'il ya des sujets
majeurs sur lequel il faut qu'on se
penche et bah ça c est pour ça qu eric
zemmour veut vraiment regrettable et le
français des calculs moi je réponds à la
question de la branche de médecine on
parle de l'école avec ses mini forme
c'est pas le programme d'éducation eric
et mon dieu mais on est d'accord que
c'est pas de chance
c'est exactement ça alors l'essentiel
c'est la maîtrise du français du calcul
j'ai un peu réfléchi à la question je me
dis c'est un sentiment d'appartenance à
un groupe le même uniforme et pour moi
de quoi en coton dans notre société
française on manque de commun en fait
qu'est-ce qui fait le communiqué le
commun au départ on la prend dans la
famille je suis tombé à l'école c'est là
que le groupe s'élargit si on crée pas
du commun à l'école à mon avis on a on
aura du mal à
favoriser sentiment d'appartenance à la
nation par exemple c'est exactement ce
que disait donc du coup à mais
finalement c'est une obsession
[Rires]
on
rapporte
qu sa bonne dynamique on se rapproche
mais je constate c'est moi où je suis
resté vous êtes
des mondes alors la réalité sentiment
d'appartenance et un petit sujet
sentiment d'appartenance parce que
justement quelqu'un disait je crois dans
le reportage oui mais c'est les couleurs
de peau oui mais des couleurs de peau
oui entre sait comment nous sommes tous
différents nos parcours de nos origines
la couleur de peau mais c'est pas un
c'est pas un problème c'est assez
différent cela mais est-ce qu'on pose de
la donne est différente ce cri du commun
et je pense que l'uniforme donc un bel
uniforme que les gamins porterait ça
peut effectivement créé un phénomène de
groupe et de groupe soudé dans une
équipe de sport berne apprenez donc
l'exemple de ces pygmées n'allons pas de
si loin le sport tout simplement qu'est
ce qui fait qu'on appartient à une
équipe qu'on sorte le même maillot oui
oui là on regarde pas défenseur attaque
un gros petit noir blanc on appartient à
une même équipe donc on partage les
valeurs communes et je pense qu'à
république aujourd'hui ce qu'il nous
manque au delà de nos différences de nos
origines de nos religions de nos
croyances c'est de partager des valeurs
communes et l'école quel est le meilleur
lieu pour partager des valeurs
universelles valeurs républicaines la
native de laïcité que valeurs du cac
tinto moi je pense que ça n'est pas un
moyen de gommer les inégalités sociales
donc ça les atténuent ça ne les gomme
pas sur ça favorise le sentiment
d'appartenance et puis dernier point on
parle souvent du manque d'autorité à
l'école mais moi j'ai le sentiment que
la tenue restaurant petit côté strict
dont on a besoin quand tu portes de
tenue si en plus tu dis qu en choeur
entonne un atlas tout le monde se lève
je trouve que ça ça créé des mécanismes
de respect qui sont aujourd'hui
absolument nécessaire dont nous manquons
mais encore une fois ça ne fait pas une
politique d'éducation donc ça ne
pénalisera pas